Chapter 18 of "The Mandalorian" features
Din Djarin using the Darksaber once again,
but he still hasn't fully mastered
the strange weapon. But his failure
to wield it competently is more
complicated than you might think.
The idea of a black lightsaber sure
sounds like something that would live
in a teenage "Star Wars" fan's
sketchbook. And yet, it's canon,
and becoming ever more important to the
franchise. Since being introduced in "Star Wars:
The Clone Wars," the Darksaber has popped up
in both "Rebels" and "The Mandalorian." It's
an ancient weapon with a rich history
tied to both the Jedi and Mandalore,
and now it rests safely in the capable hands
of Din Djarin. Or, well, mostly capable.
Despite training intensely with the blade in
"The Book of Boba Fett," Din still struggles
with it in "The Mandalorian" Chapter 18. His form
is awkward, and he seems to be fighting against
the Darksaber as much as he's fighting with it.
The Darksaber was forged by an ancient Mandalorian
Jedi named Tarre Vizsla. After his death, it
was stolen from the Jedi Temple by his clan,
and since then, it's been passed down.
Traditionally, the weapon is won in combat,
but earning it doesn't guarantee you'll
be able to wield it, as Din finds out.
Like all lightsabers, the Darksaber is designed
to tightly focus energy from the crystal at its
core. Kanan Jarrus gives Sabine Wren some
very useful advice in "Star Wars Rebels."
"You're not fighting with a simple blade as
much as you are directing a current of power."
Like Din, Sabine struggles at first to control
the energy of the blade. Kanan blames this on
her inner turmoil, saying that her thoughts and
feelings are also channeled through the weapon.
When she begins to master it, he says that
it's because she's connecting to the blade.
The Armorer tells Din something similar
in "The Book of Boba Fett" when he's
training with the Darksaber. He says
that each swing makes it heavier,
and she says it's because he's "fighting
against the blade." According to her,
his lack of dexterity is the result of a lack of
focus. In other words, Din has a mental block when
it comes to the Darksaber, which is clearly
still in place in "The Mandalorian" Season 3.
Perhaps he's too concerned with redeeming himself
in the eyes of his people. Or maybe it's his
paternal feelings for Grogu that are throwing him
off. Whatever the cause, the effects are clear.
Still, there is hope. Just as Sabine, Pre Vizsla,
and Bo-Katan all came to master the Darksaber,
so too can Din. The main issue is probably just
that his priorities are elsewhere at the moment.
Why is the Darksaber so much more challenging
to master than a regular lightsaber? Well,
for starters, that might not actually be true.
Most of the lightsaber training we've seen in
"Star Wars" involves Force-sensitive characters,
who have a natural advantage in wielding the
iconic weapons. The Darksaber is more often
used by Mandalorians who have no natural
Force power. As such, they have to adapt to a
tool that was not designed with them in mind.
Even still, the Darksaber seems more
challenging to control. Jedi younglings
have better dexterity with their blades than
Din, and there are numerous instances across
the franchise of lightsabers being used
by characters who aren't Force-sensitive.
Why is the Darksaber in particular so difficult?
There are a few possible explanations. For one,
it's a much older design than the other
lightsabers we see in "Star Wars," so
it's possible that its energy is less
restrained. There's precedent for this,
as Kylo Ren's lightsaber also uses unstable power
to yield a more forceful weapon. The
Darksaber is also a fully unique model,
so there could be some secret Mandalorian
features that make it different to wield.
It's hard to say for sure because we've never
seen a character who isn't Force-sensitive
train this much with a regular lightsaber.
When Kanan instructs Sabine in "Rebels,"
he seems to know what she's experiencing with
the Darksaber despite not being familiar with
it himself. Maybe Jedi are simply better
prepared to connect with such a weapon, or
maybe they have a built-in connection since they
construct their own lightsabers as younglings.